الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرنسكي وفي تعليقه
على الحزمه العاشره للعقوبات قال ان فرض
العقوبات على روسيا سيستمر حتى لا يبقى
شيء من العدوان بحسب تعبيره واشار
زيلينسكي في خطابه المسائي الى ان
اوكرانيا تواصل العمل على توسيعه هذه
العقوبات على الصناعه النوويه الروسيه وكل
من يشارك في برنامج الصواريخ
سيستمر فرض العقوبات حتى لا يتبقى شيء من
العدوان الروسي في الحزمه العاشره التي من
الواضح انها ليست الاخيره خطوات وعقوبات
جديده وقويه ضد الصناعه العسكريه والقطاع
المالي للدوله الارهابيه وضد الدعاه الذين
اغرقوا المجتمع الروسي في الاكاذيب
ويحاولون نشر اكاذبهم للعالم كله يعمل
دبلوماسيون والدوله باكملها على توسيع
العقوبات العالميه والاوروبيه على وجه
الخصوص على الصناعه النوويه الروسيه وعلى
كل من يشارك في برنامج الصواريخ والابتزاز
النووي للدوله الارهابيه